[Music]  how could you let Ballarat just get away  you're fired  he's very good miss Natalie admit what  are you doing since you don't have a job  I just wanted your help  ah excuse me hey hey could you oh cool  no I I was saying I put my seriously Wow  I really must have a word with you on  behalf of your twin brother drew what we  brother my brother  do you like my god  [Music]  having love this come look at him over  here would make you better but he's so  mad you might be the beautiful wife oh  wait doctor this place is amazing  ignite by gas your I'm not really  interesting racist grill amazing a blood  hey kitten bugs readies and continue the  family tradition  you and me no I left that life behind me  just one  [Music]  I'm going in  [Music]  it does not mean that you're going back  to being villain you got  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you